So that was surprising to me,
that was not where I originally went.
I didn't see the two thirds popping out
because really like you said there's no
where's the thirds.
There's nothing in the set up of
the problem that had thirds in it.
>> Right and so the way that I come to
that answer is I think about counting.
So before when I said well if
I know there's only one and
you tell me that one.
The x is actually right, that's a one.
It's like also telling me,
y is not it, and z is not it.
And kind of the intuition here is that
if the probability of human correct
is 0.8, it's almost like I'm
giving eight-tenths of a count.
That's like saying that you
got eight tenths of an x,
of a count going towards x and
then 0.2 for y and 0.2 for z,
which you'll notice that
if you normalize that out,
works out exactly to be two
thirds one sixth and one sixth.
>> Yeah so that counting thing
turns out to be very powerful and
we can derive a more
general version of this.
So this quiz is actually,
both of the quiz I gave you were
actually designed to be easy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah and
do you know what makes them easy?
What makes them easy is that we
only had one, one piece of data.
You see you try to take
action x in state s and
you ended up being told that was good.
But what if you had done it ten or
twenty times and sometimes x was said
to be good, sometimes said to be bad,
sometimes y was said to be good,
sometimes said to be bad.
Then this kind of natural, this sort of
process you went through still works but
you have to keep track
of a lot more things and
this counting argument actually helps.
And it comes from exactly
the crystal clear generative model
that uses Bayes rule
that you came up with.
So I'm going to actually
write it down for
you and we can talk about it for
a little bit, okay.
>> Yeah no I'd like to
see the general form.